hello everybody and welcome to a
brand-new let's play of the amnesia
custom story the machine by Dai lo by
doodle-ooh it is the year or 1887 you
and your wife Nina no I don't think this
guy's Swedish I've been invited to Lord
Haris newsfeeds which was going to
happen inside of his own Manor at the
countryside of Norfolk ah the main
person of that event was Lord Haris of
Norfolk was widely regarded as an
eccentric and odd engineer like me
due to his researches on steam machines
and engines on that night 19th of
October 1887 after several hours of
feasting you felt drunk
I didn't that's pretty good sounds like
me you made your way to your guest room
you've laid on the floor and fallen
asleep ok alright so I got drunk and
fell asleep woke up with some girl's
hand in my pants
true story
all right let's do loading screen let's
see if you can scare me
unlikely you know how awesomely tough
and manly and brave I am I don't get
scared
nothing sanity is dangerously low that's
not a good way to start out Oh huh wha I
can't really play like this but I'll try
yeah Oh wall area
ah I was no sir my head how long have I
been asleep I need something to drink
how about some 151 oh no miss 151
actually I really don't I told the story
in the dead space let's play about being
151 we don't get along Adam dangerously
low water bucket of water drink it shove
it in your hey did I drink it did I oh
okay I guess I did hold the left mouse
down and move the mouse in order to move
the door I know I know how to play I'm a
little bit of a pro at this game
what that that was a little dramatic for
it being locked don't you think wait
wait wait wait huh huh
what happened what happened huh did I
miss the scare Oh oh yeah I got what
happened what happened I don't even know
something just I did Oh Nina
oh no Nina my beloved he's gone Oh Nina
your beloved or as Emma I have to find
my wife sorry I spit I'm just so
concerned for my wife I'm splitting with
concern and the deep ocean and any boat
ah who are you oh you're that's the UM
that's the mom from Justine this
painting at the bomb ah Lily do oh no my
wife I'm so concerned for her thing ah
ha ha oh it's just just a corpse nothing
wrong with the corpse nothing scary
about a corpse either I send up who's
that
who are you how did you die why are you
naked
what kind of party was this ah oh no
class no class can't hold their liquor
mmm huh what Otto my last adventure I
can't stop that unless you guys like it
my Swedish accent write in the comments
if you want me to read everything in
Swedish accent from now on as for now I
am working on something completely
different the machine I have created
some space underneath my mansion to
provide a good lab for my
experimentation I am trying to use steam
as a power source my trusted adviser mr.
Paul has decided to hire a group of
specialists to work for me people with
last names at her first names never good
lessons how do you know you're all great
people great people and they need some
work space not sure now they are
performing well tomorrow we will be
testing new steam-powered door
if everything is fine I will start mass
production also I got some new ideas for
human machine maybe in close future I
will be able to make a mechanical human
being this idea doesn't let me sleep at
night good English you got towards the
end of that start that ok think I kind
of weird toward the end hello
ah ha ha ha yeah yeah yeah oh yeah I'm
the best I'm so great can't handle it
well let me guess up totally gonna call
this to use this on this wow yeah there
it is yeah I'm so smart monsters where
is everybody
I don't care all I care about is my wife
Oh where's my wife
they took my wife yeah chair come here
come here
ha ha Oh give me what what back yah yah
yah yah wah
okay
I'm dumping them on your table you think
of me now
hey chair wow I'm breaking your [ __ ] ha
ha hey all people should not invite me
to mansions I just end up breaking
everything limors
gonna bring my ass smash come on wait
what's that
well done it's nothing
crap uh-huh uh-huh yeah no area right
here yeah yeah yeah yeah okay all right
was I supposed to do something I don't
know
I'll just have Oh blood I'm so scared
Oh a shirt it's a haunted shirt oh I
Dunsey more oh wait uh-uh
can't hide from me okay anyway oh you
two here
oh hello huh wha I'm behind the barrels
we are look butch ah ha ha ha ha
yeah I win I win I win I found it
come on give me some oh here let me have
em baby I found it I found something ah
ah fine whatever
don't matter to me I just found him at
scripta but how can I open it ha ha what
but I'm a crowbar my man wait where
where where's my color fine ah know what
oh you're the daughter your Justine
that's Justine that's just Dean's Papa
who just came murdered it all comes down
to murder all is someone's gonna murder
someone else it is not waste so much oil
I got plenty I actually gave me a full
tank of oil right at the beginning ok
there check his desk I check his desk
when I'm good right
huh yeah it's all the way across the
room
Krong right why this chair facing
backwards chair lead the haunted evil
anti chair maybe that's something inside
to open the damn thing
jiggle-jiggle this of the decide oh I
wish I could know what it was but were
Friedrich stone-cutting company 2600
pounds
Madison 1250 blah blah blah
dear mr. Paul we need please we need to
cut down the costs tear the workers to
stop working on Saturdays we don't need
them now also I would like to see your
weekly report why are you being so late
oh useful was this oh it's a writing
dude dad oh damn it okay I need
obviously something else too
um open the thingy and the door over
there
so who down here who what um oh wow what
care what it gonna be okay Wow come on
yep put good huh natural it's it's it's
unholy seriously what the hell happened
okay
I'm taking the back it's just so wrong
whatever all right um listen cuz it's
switch okay turn the spit cook me some
Dindin I did a whole lot of nothing
alright come on this has to be something
look maybe it opened a switch second oh
yeah you know maybe the banging day come
on wasting oil huh yeah yep
throw something at it throw a rock at it
ah basket probably not best joy potted
plant plant or plant a pot
No course back in this time heroin and
cocaine cooking cocaine were like
available at your local corner store oh
that's like no light at all
that's not even lighting up anything
what's the point of that a stupid L is a
waste I don't even have many of those
tinderboxes is there no oh okay maybe
somehow this chair coming in the wall
made that door closed but I let me
backtrack a bit this wasn't the only way
right I think up revenge boom bang it
yep yeah screw you crap ah anything
under the stairs Nelson hi yeah it's
still ugly all right no it's insulting
the scene I'll go in this one first
hello oh is this the other door to the
uh oh wow so wrong
it's it oh wow it's a boy yay
I just birthed the chair yeah you saw it
so I here first huh you're making noises
die break the game I wouldn't doubt it
not even any music playing it's like
totally a full-on solitude going on here
I look it wasn't like it was locked or
anything it just didn't let me through
what the heck also the lighting is weird
this fire isn't giving off any ambient
light I mean only the windows are it's
very strange
not sure what the dealio is okay um
maybe there's a secret book to pull
that'll open the door uh-uh doesn't look
like it these none of these look oh wait
what was that
no nothing please look like they're the
pull a book on that I've seen in the
other games I mean there are individual
ones obviously nothing ah something in
here so let me open it
clunk clunk use the violin on it here
use the bow string yeah yeah yeah yeah
easy chair yeah okay well haha back to
the old style of markiplier let's place
where I get lost lost like nobody's
business
hi what let me over maybe some in here
it's dark
yeah it's dark I'm afraid that if I use
another tinderbox it's gonna be like
that let here watch
oh my cast a little bit alright ah those
are tricky goes the switch in here which
right here right here
ha you know I get back ha ha what what
you kidding me suddenly ah ok whatever
it don't matter new tools that scared me
way more than I should've
not that anything scared me whoops
I was embarrassing ok got a hollow
needle well good what good is a hollow
needle and why is it so quiet
why is there no meas going on was this
and yeah
ah okay okay seriously I can't believe I
got freaked out that much just by a
little explosion Oh
FQ a very complicated mine what and why
did the switch be work ah
I don't know I don't know maybe here ah
what am I supposed to do
oh oh the the cabinet the cabinet
cabinet probably has a key in it oh I'm
stupid I got it I got it actually I
don't got it this is gonna have to wait
until next time thank you guys so much
for watching hope you're enjoying the
new let's play I like I like that some
of the things they've done the
atmosphere seems dastardly anyway thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next part
bye bye